I remember that life like it was
yesterday yeah it's not like you're
waking up in the morning bagging up
bundles with a mask on sometimes without
a mask on fentanyl where nobody knew
about that [__] and then even think
about this [__] just reminding me right
now like what the [__] was I doing I was
30 years old three-time felon selling
dope hand in hand oh that's crazy it's
the same I might as well been playing in
a [__] highway what was going through
your mind what was going through my mind
was this is what I always done I already
accepted the consequence of whatever
happened just saying that just reminds
me like what the [__] was I doing woke
up looked at my girl every day thinking
like I might have to leave this [__] ah
I'm saying it's like chicken get ugly
I'm saying how in love we were at that
time looking at my daughter to from
having goddamn FBI cases and [__] to
being the representative of the bills to
Byron Brown declaring [__] Conway the
machine day in Buffalo you know because
I feel like it's insane you know that's
the craziest [__] in the world yeah I
mean that's the crazy [__] in the world
it's a whole new life